eléonore belge jean-philippe du goire
bonjour merci à tous les deux d'avoir
accepté d'échanger de débattre ce matin
sur rtl france on va parler situation
sanitaire emmanuel macron est donc
rentré de vacances premier dossier chaud
pour l'exécutif la rentrée des classes
le protocole a lancé hier sera
pratiquement le même qu'en juin dernier
selon le ministre de l'éducation et pas
de passes sanitaires pour rentrer
regarder
s'il s'agit de rentrer dans un
établissement scolaire il n'y aura pas
de passe ni pour les parents ni pour les
élèves ni pour les enseignants l'école
doit rester accessible à tous c'est
pourquoi il n'y aura pas de passe annie
terre c'est notre philosophie depuis le
début de la crise alors on a d'un côté
le gouvernement qui mise sur le pass
sanitaires pour endiguer l'épidémie de
l'eau de pâtes pas de passes sanitaires
à l'école notamment pour les enseignants
est-ce que selon vous il aurait dû être
élargi aux enseignants comme en italie
par exemple eléonore baise
large aux enseignants maintenant on voit
bien qu'entre le les enseignants n'ont
pas de passé militaire les français
doivent avoir un passé militaire pour
aller faire leurs courses dans un
hypermarché on vient déjà il ya aussi
une
difficulté du pôle au gouvernement en
fait avoir quelque chose de clair et je
trouve que c'est un petit peu même si
les français doivent avoir un bep
sanitaire les enseignants également un
manque de clarté donc vous nous dites
jean-philippe eu du goût et clémence est
cette rentrée elle manque de clarté dans
sa préparation selon vous
cet hôtel nous dira pas plus que 18 mois
espère que depuis 18 mois par rapport
aux écoles collèges lycées c'est ce
qu'on constate en tant qu'élus locaux en
tant que maire on est sur des pattes de
permanence sur des heures dressions des
comprendre grosso modo ce qui nous est
demandé pour la rentrée fait 2 ou prou
quelque chose d'extrêmement preuve de ce
qu'il y avait à la fin de l'année
scolaire passée au ouaki à des
modifications essentiellement pour les
collégiens lycéens puisque un câble
covin général plus forcément la
fermeture de toute une classe donc c'est
une possibilité de laisser un petit peu
plus d'enfants en présentiel depuis 18
mois maintenant beaucoup d'enfants
notamment les plus jeunes ont quand même
souffert de l'éloignement on a des cas
de décrochage scolaire avec qui ce
compte il y avait la question sur lequel
le gouvernement a créé un pack bleu lui
passe sanitaires dans les écoles puisque
je rappelle que au début de l'été il
était question de le mettre en place et
finalement le dessus ça n'a pas été
suivi ce qui est à venir parce que ça
serait revenu à exclure des enfants du
scolaire la question des enseignants
pour qu'ils finalement ce n'est pas
demander alors effectivement ce que
lisent et madame on peut se demander
pourquoi telle profession et pas telle
autre mais toujours est il que le seul
point de vue là la rive est arrêté non
ce qu'on peut peut-être regretter outre
le fait que les consignes comme
d'habitude on extrêmement tard c'est
qu'on continue à fermer intégralement
des classes d'école maternelle et
d'élémentaire plutôt que de procéder à
un test salivaire qui pourrait permettre
de s'assurer en l'espace d'une journée
savoir si des enfants qui ont côtoyé un
câble cohen de préville soient
contaminés ou pas soit contagieux ou pas
essayons de maintenir un peu depuis
l'enfance présentiel en tout cas le pass
sanitaire lui provoque la contestation
et d'une partie de la population
ils sont nombreux de plusieurs samedi
dans les villes de france est ce que le
gouvernement il a raison minimiser cette
contestation ou au contraire et il ya un
risque à la rentrée que les rangs des
protestataires grossistes et de nos
rebelles selon vous
écoutez minimiser les minimiser les
manifestations c'est minimiser ce que ce
que pensent les français sur le pass
anita qui est évidemment déjà quelque
chose de liberticide par le fait que
simplement on dit non il n'y a pas
d'obligation vaccinale mais il ya un
position du vaccin puisque pour pénétrer
dans les lieux publics comme par exemple
pour les centres commerciaux de plus de
28 mètres carrés où les gens besoin de
faire leurs courses et vous rappeler que
pendant les confinements il y avait
quand même une exception pour les
produits de première nécessité il y a
également car également une imposition
du vaccin puisque le test pcr va passer
à 45 euros je crois à partir du mois de
septembre donc forcément il y aura
obligation vaccinale et puis il y avait
également aussitôt cette profession des
restaurateurs qui déjà ont été très
touchés pendant deuxième confinement
quand être serré mais et qui maintenant
sont aujourd'hui plus de 40% est dans
une situation qui est une situation de
crise est assez grave et qui n'ont plus
de qui perdent un chiffre d'affaires
considérable et ça veut dire au
supérieur sont des familles qui sont
impactés donc c'est cette imposition
dupas sanitaires cette obligation
puisque encore une fois une thèse qui a
passé à 45 euros à la rentrée et bien va
forcément obligé les gens à à se faire
le vaccin à se faire vacciner est
divisée donc une certaine aussi volonté
du gouvernement du cas où une
cinquantaine de diviser les français
entre les non vaccinés et des vaccinés
effectivement le mouvement tu contre le
mas sanitaires 7 cette obligation et 7
cette absence de cette obligation qui
entraîne une absence de choix évidemment
je pense forcément grossières alors
petite précision ans à la mi-octobre a
que les tests pcr seront seront payants
jeu jean philippe dugoin clément vous
c'est vous le sentez aussi voulu lever
comme une obligation vaccinale
finalement toutes ces mesures qui ont
été prises ces derniers mois et qui
continuent d'être prises
très également on peut être pour ou
contre le vaccin l'obligation vaccinale
facilite le choix qui a été pris par le
gouvernement avec l'allocution public le
2 juillet c'est d'aller vers une
obligation vaccinale masqué au travers
du passé r en le mettant en place de
telle manière que ça fait peser un poids
social poussant les gens à service il
est alors ça aurait peut-être été clair
c'est ce que suggérait robert ménard
talent et il ya une obligation de la
vaccination est ce que vous feriez vous
il sait pas forcément ce que j'aurais
voulu mais ça aurait d'une certaine
manière de le mérite d'être clair la c1
qui peut au moins deux cas on se rend
compte que mécaniquement
pratiquement rendre une vaccination
obligatoire c'est quelque chose de
quasiment impossible puisque ya pas
contrôler des gens enfin on mesure bien
la difficulté des choses donc il ya ce
choix qui a été fait par le gouvernement
on mesure aujourd'hui on est quand même
sur une très grande partie de la
population est vaccinée on échoue
aujourd'hui un peu plus de 47 milliard
de personnes qui ont reçu une première
dose le gouvernement espère 50 millions
à la fin de l'été on y sera peu ou prou
le public cible vaccinable crois que
c'est de l'ordre de 58 millions de
personnes on voit bien ici à la fin des
remboursements des tests pcr ou
antigénique
au parlement ils vont être payés en
début octobre on sera sur une énorme
majorité des personnes pouvant prétendre
à la vaccination qui vont l'être après
il faut pas minimiser les personnes qui
peuvent être inquiète qui peuvent avoir
beaucoup de doutes qui peuvent avoir des
peurs que ce soit pour elle que ce soit
pour leur entourage il ya aussi froid
une question de d'information
d'explication il doit continuer à être
fait voilà aujourd'hui la réalité est
que le vaccin sauver des vies même si je
conçois parfaitement qu'on puisse avoir
des inquiétudes qu'on puisse avoir des
peurs et que c'est quelque chose qui
respecte alors l'actualité en france ces
dernières heures c'est aussi cette
nouvelle fusillade dans la nuit de
samedi à dimanche à marseille trois
morts sur fond de règlements de compte
et le trafic de drogue voyez ce que
déclarait d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'intérieur il ya quelques jours comme
mesure notamment pour lutter contre les
trafics de drogue
je connais plein d'endroits bourgeois où
l'on consomme du cannabis
on consomme de la cocaïne et dont on se
dit pourquoi c'est le bordel à marseille
pourquoi c'est difficile en région
parisienne les personnes qui sont deux
catégories sociales plus élevés vont
vivre ce trafic parfois j'ai dit au
préfet de police pour paris
au directeur de la police nationale que
je veux aussi des contrôles contre la
drogue dans les beaux quartiers pour
éviter cette consommation alors
verbaliser les consommateurs dans les
beaux quartiers est ce que c'est une
priorité pour mettre fin au trafic et
aux règlements de comptes selon vous est
le north bay
l'a prise la priorité déjà c'est de
s'attaquer aux trafiquants lui-même de
s'y attaquer réellement de manière alors
d'une réponse policière mais aussi qu'il
y ait une réponse judiciaire une réponse
judiciaire pénal c'est un strict
aujourd'hui moi j'habite dans les
quartiers nord fusillade qui a touché 1
7 enfant de 14 ans voulait à côté de
chez moi je vois tous les jours des
effectifs de police et de crs de police
nationale qui sont déployés autour des
cités autour des points de trafic de
droits qui ne se cachent pas qu'ils sont
à ciel ouvert et bien des policiers qui
qui ne bouge pas un devancé devant ces
trafiquants parce que ce n'est pas la
fois des policiers c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas forcément d'ordre voilà et pas
forcément derrière aussi de réponse
judiciaire figure qu'on va arrêter ses
shoes comme on dis ces gardiens ces
guetteurs et puis ils vont passer deux
heures de rappel à la loi et revenir le
lendemain sur le terrain ils sont de
retour donc c'est vraiment que je crois
que le gouvernement pourrait s'attaquer
enfin parce que ça fait des années
qu'ils ne ce qui ne le fait pas enfin au
trafic de drogue que ce soit au plus bas
de l'échelle et on les gère
effectivement pour casser ce système
mais s'y attaquer c'est s'y attaquer
avec une véritable réponse judiciaire
des rien qui soit claire qui soit net
qui entraîne des sanctions pénales et
qui empêche finalement que c'est que des
drames pareil à marseille arrive et
ailleurs mais à mars et on s'enfonce
effectivement dans une ultra violence
dans les quartiers et dans les quartiers
doit donc on vient entendre vous disiez
manque de volonté pas de réponse
judiciaire hier vous rejoignez ce
constat jean philippe dugoin clément
déjà je voulais avoir une pensée par nos
forces de l'ordre policiers parce que
quand on parle de ce type de situation
aujourd'hui on est comme ça pour les
gens qui sont extrêmement seul qui sont
souvent les derniers allaient dans ses
quartiers à aller au contact allait se
battre pour tout simplement essayer de
restaurer de maintenir un état de droit
je n'ai déjà avoir une pensée pour
ensuite globalement on constate une
société de plus en plus violente de plus
en plus avec un rajeunissement un
abaissement de l'âge de la violence qui
d'ailleurs contribuer aussi à une autre
perte de repères ce qu'on a pu constater
à marseille qui peut être amplifié par
le fait qu' on a des quartiers
particulièrement paupérisée qu'on est
une bible depuis des années des trafics
qui perdurent des situations qui perdure
on constate faut pas se leurrer dans
beaucoup d'autres communes de france il
n'y a pas de frontières intangibles
d'une commune à l'autre et effectivement
ce bouclier la consommation d'un certain
nombre de personnes la consommation des
quartiers riches c'est aussi qu'ils
aient trafic qui perdure moi je crois
profondément que on a un problème majeur
sur le trafic de drogues en général sur
le coeur d'avoir une réponse pénale
particulièrement dure qu au delà du
trafic de drogue dont on en parle très
peu viable du trafic d'armes parce qu on
est aujourd'hui sur les trafiquants qui
sont armés qui disposent d'armes de
guerre ça pose la question au delà de la
drogue de la question de l'armement de
la question de l'arrivée d'altitude du
trafic qui est fait sur ces armes et
puis d'une manière générale une réponse
group et global dans ces quartiers on
mesure bien que un gosse de 14 15 ans
qui peut gagner plus que les adultes
parce qu'il faut aller lui expliquer
qu'il faut qu'il restait que qu'il faut
qu'il travaille ça pose aussi un
problème général un point global oui des
moyens donnés aux forces de l'ordre de
la réponse pénale mais aussi
l'enseignement aussi du travail
d'accompagnement qui est fait auprès des
familles pour éviter quand ils peuvent
encore l'être que des gosses des enfants
gris ça nécessite une réponse globale
cécile en réponse avec les douanes qui
cite également une mobilisation des as
d'étrangers à se renouveler en lien aux
relations avec des pays dont on sait
qu'ils couvrent qu'ils permettent à 100
le trafic s'est véritablement si on
continue à travailler en silo poste par
poste pour le père paul là on n'arrivera
rien dans dix ans on sera à nouveau
d'autres dans la même émission à faire
le même débat télé au north bay c'est la
paupérisation de ces quartiers qui est
la cause de ces fusillades de c2c trafic
de drogue c'est l'abandon au niveau de
l'éducation c'est toutes ces choses là
qui font qu'aujourd'hui il dit à ces
dames
pas uniquement parce que vous savez les
quartiers où ça se produit que je vois
tous les jours ce sont des quartiers qui
sont quand même tous des quartiers qui
ont été largement abordés par la
politique de la ville ce sont des
quartiers où l'état déversent des
millions des milliards d'euros depuis
des années tous les deux ans par exemple
dans la rénovation lauber il ya des
écoles il ya des crèches qui a toutes
les structures il ya des bus il ya des
transports donc on peut pas dire que ce
sont des quartiers paupérisés il y a pas
contre à l'intérieur de ces quartiers
des racailles qui tiennent ces kits hier
les trafics qui le font au vu et au su
des services de police et de justice
parce que encore une fois eh bien il
n'ya pas ils savent très bien ils
connaissent parfaitement la loi ils
savent très bien qu'il n'y aura pas de
réponse pénale réel derrière c'est pas
avec monsieur dupont moretti ministre
garde des sceaux qui est qui se fait
applaudir dans les prisons évidemment
qu'il va y avoir une certaine fermeté
qui va être dit m qui va être fait au
niveau de l'état donc ce ne sont pas des
quartiers paupérisés ce sont des
quartiers qui sont rénovés tous les deux
ans et je peux vous le dire je j habite
devant jeu jacques gervis je les vois
quand vous voyez encore une fois des
chauffes cagoulés dès 10h du matin qui
sont là à narguer des véhicules de
police et encore une fois les la police
elle fait son travail et ils sont très
peu trop peu nombreux
et bien on peut pas dire véritablement
qu'il soit qu'ils aient peur de faire de
commettre un quelconque trafic et encore
moins après de se tuer et de tuer des
gamins de 14 ans avec des balles perdues
bon enfant de huit ans des gamins note
on se demande pourquoi ils sont dans la
rue à 23 heures là aussi il ya une
question une vraie responsabilisation
des parents à faire donc
c'est la faute des parents finalement
jean philippe dugoin clément cette
situation comment viens de l'entendre
mais on a un certain nombre de mômes qui
ne sont plus suivis où il ya des départs
au qui n'assume plus requis n'a su plus
il ya de différent cas il ya des câbles
à en forme de chemin foutiste qui est
absolument inacceptable qui est
intolérable et sur laquelle la société
doit répondre bois de des sanctions à
des parents qui ne ce que leurs enfants
après faut aussi me dirais qu'il ya des
parents qui sont complètement dépassés
on m'avait situation des refus c'est pas
propre à des quartiers populaires ou à
des quartiers paupérisés mais on a des
situations de mère célibataire avec des
adolescents qui ont pris le pouvoir chez
eux et c'est aussi le travail de l'état
pour le coup sûr des services sociaux de
venir à l'accompagner remplacer ray et
luc et dans ces cas-là faut mesurer
certaines certaines familles d'ailleurs
plus de familles il ya des familles
monoparentales avec essayer de s'en
sortir et qui ne tiennent plus les lost
suffit pas que c'est la majorité les
pacsés local systématique mais c'est
aussi décalé existe mais on ne peut pas
être dans une dog image complètement
monolithique ou caricatural maintenant
c'est vrai que la démission parentale
qui est d inconscience parental qui est
des phénomènes de refus ou drj et
l'imaginé par nature son enfant et comme
soin d'ouvrir à parce qu'elle aime bien
ça on le mesure dans toutes les classes
sociales quand une élue locale
alors concernant toujours la sécurité
intérieure et dans le contexte de la
prise de pouvoir des talibans en
afghanistan le candidat à la
présidentiel xavier bertrand a dit
vouloir interdire le salafisme en france
en taclant au passage emmanuel macron
regarder
depuis cinq ans emmanuel macron a fait
preuve d'une naïveté confondante sur la
question il n'a absolument pas pris au
sérieux la menace que fait peser
l'islamisme radical sur nos sécurités
nos valeurs l'islamisme radical n'est
pas une religion c'est une idéologie qui
à l'échelle veut détruire notre vision
du monde et de l'homme notre identité ce
qu'est la france emmanuel macron et naïf
il faut interdire le salafisme en france
est-ce qu'il a raison xavier bertrand et
l'honneur baise
des xi et les refrains qui parle
d'interdire le salafisme en france alors
qu'il a largement contribué aussi à
l'extension de deux mosquées salafistes
dans sa propre région c'est toujours
assez croustillant interdire le
salafisme en france et déjà empêché
aussi les filières bien évidemment c'est
déjà empêché des filières d'immigration
massive qui sont en train déjà les plats
france ouvre ses portes aux réfugiés
afghans par exemple dont on sait que 95
% sont favorables à la charia que 85 %
sont favorables à la lapidation des
femmes las pour eux évidemment il n'y a
pas de pass and i ter la france ouvre
largement ses portes la ville de
marseille d'ailleurs également avec
monsieur payant qui qui de manière tout
à fait inconsidérés et irresponsable
oppose un accueil immodéré de ces
réfugiés moi j'attends que tous ces gens
qui proposent les accueillir les
accueille d'abord en priorité chez eux
dans leur domicile voilà sur la question
du salafisme il est bien évident que ça
fait des années qu'on dit et que nous
dénonçons à son mouvement national cette
islamisation dans les quartiers qui est
absolument partout et est bien que
malgré tout rien n'est fait pour le
moment réellement parce que c'est une
mosquée qui est fermé au radical qui est
fermé mais pas la salanque alors que les
dirigeants politiques savent très bien
et le gouvernement sait très bien qui
comment fonctionnent les filières du
salafisme qui est salafistes qui
radicalise et que ce qu'on s'aperçoit
lorsqu'il ya malheureusement un attentat
et bien que ces personnes sont connues
des services de renseignement en clair
aujourd'hui par exemple avec la crise de
l'afghanistan est là flux de réfugiés
afghans c'est totalement irresponsable
du gouvernement d'accueillir ces gens là
chez nous dans la mesure où et bien
parmi eux il y a effectivement des gens
qui sont bien clairement qu'ils sont
censés furent les talibans mais qui en
sont aussi jean philippe dugoin clément
votre réponse pour pour conclure sur
cette question de l'arrivée de migrants
en france
l'arrivée de migrants est confrontée
depuis des années il ya une chose qui
passe à des licences et que le lien
semble d'alban qui se sont engagés pour
la france qui se sont battus pour la
france ont travaillé pour la france pour
l'état pour son armée pour ces ong pour
ces associations et il ya un devoir de
notre pays par rapport aux afghans qui
se sont engagés pour la france de les
mettre en sécurité ainsi que leurs
familles on ne peut pas faire et effet
d'ailleurs partiellement canton s'est
retirée sur françois hollande entre 2012
à 2014 avec les interprètes avec les
familles des interprètes d'abandonner
des gens derrière nous on ne peut pas
refaire en afghanistan en 2021 ce qui
était fait bel air qui en algérie c'est
quoi finalement le aujourd'hui le devoir
de la france pour vous et eléonore baez
le devour france aujourd'hui la
situation dans ce pays c'est d'abord de
protéger les français tout simplement
voilà ça c'est le devoir d'un homme
d'état c'est le devoir d'un chef d'état
ah et bien c'est ce que c'est le premier
devoir c'est de protéger son pays et les
ressortissants de son pays avant de
penser à protéger des réfugiés afghans
qu'il faut pas tout à fait confondre
avec les harkis malheureuse et
concernant la situation des femmes par
exemple il ya une tribune une pétition
lancée samedi soutenu par plusieurs
artistes et femmes politiques françaises
elle réclame justement à un accueil
inconditionnel de ces femmes jean
philippe dubois clémence est une
priorité
mais très clairement et pour le coup de
président il ne fut un grand soutien à
une position plutôt équilibré la france
ne sera à jamais de répondre seul de
prendre l'ensemble des personnes qui
veulent quitter l'afghanistan parce que
c'est un régime l'on se également une
grande partie de la population pas toute
la population mais une partie de la
population quand on pourra le quitter la
france a un devoir par rapport à ceux
qui ont servi la france
il ya aussi une réponse globale
européenne mondiale qui doit être
apportée la situation en afghanistan
aujourd'hui résultent d'un retrait
américain non préparés la france ne
pourra plus faire avec seul nous n'avons
pas les moyens nous n'en avons nous ne
sommes pas en situation de le faire est
véritablement pour l'instant signé une
pétition qui est assez qui est pas de la
part de l'état un grand merci à tous les
deux d'avoir échangé débattu sur
l'actualité en france mais revient merci
à vous jean philippe dugoin clément mary
di2 même si vice président de la région
ile de france merci à vous eléonore
baise conseillère régionale en paca